five rebounds six assists double digits
now for anthony davis
just one of eight shooting he's made all
eight of his free throws however
has four rebounds as well
again i don't know why this hasn't been
the talk
before the playoffs but this man is
shooting 43
53 from the field averaging 30 points
15 rebounds for his career
in the playoffs that's just that's just
amazing big playoff games
with new orleans davis kind of looking
at the rim as if it was
tilted sometimes the kickback gets stuck
i don't know if they're gonna the
official james williams
yeah all right maintenance
somebody called maintenance they're so
funny look at guys though they're
all trying to measure it themselves and
say yeah it's a little bit this way a
little bit that way but
every angle matters do you feel like
hanging on the rim at all i mean i know
you've lost a lot of weight during the
shutdown but
get that thing back tilted right i could
get in the old man dunk contest oh for
sure only against some old man
[Laughter]
they were right on it here so
let's see if dwight howard was the
culprit here yeah it had to be
powerful it never had the kick back back
to level
[Applause]
you know that's a oh to the great daryl
dawkins yes
shatter in the glass oh man yeah and
then he would name him too
all the names that he had with the white
house that's what's so tough about this
laker team and that's why we've seen
the evolution of style and play in this
league how do you handle three seven
footers can you beat them going small
uh like uh houston can you play
different defenses like a quinn playing
behind other guys i mean the league is
just in such a great place right now
because the players and coaches
have raised the game to such a level
that if you aren't
creative if you aren't humble if you
can't adjust you're not going to be in
this game for long